and finally new rules someone has to
tell me why we keep allowing social
media and our very lives as social
creatures to be dictated by the most
socially awkward person in history
in case you missed it a couple of weeks
ago facebook announced that the name of
the parent company has been changed to
meta
the better to reflect mark zuckerberg's
new master plan for what he has called
an embodied internet where instead of
viewing content you are in it
because why spend hours typing on
facebook to argue with your
brother-in-law about ivory mechdon
when your avatar can yell at his avatar
in person
well
not in person of course in the matrix
where mark wants us all to live he says
anything you do in real life can be done
in this new metaverse
playing cards sitting in a park
getting a bad haircut
it's easy you just put on goggles gloves
and i don't know suction cups on your
balls and
now you're in the magical land of the
metaverse because everyone looks cool
with [ __ ] strapped to their head
in the metaverse you can tour the
pyramids or have a sword fight with a
duck
all without having to leave the comfort
of your parents basement
we we've all seen this depicted in
movies like ready player one where an
elaborate metaverse serves as a retreat
for people to escape the misery of
existence something i always felt was
better handled by weed but
but i'm not a visionary like mark
zuckerberg i tried virtual reality once
and i don't know i put on the goggles
and suddenly i was in a hot air balloon
over france and then i was riding a
broomstick around hogwarts and
then i was in the bathroom throwing up
it was like getting roofied by walt
disney
here's some actual footage
from zuckerberg's recent presentation
about what this new world will look like
that's right you're at a concert with a
friend who seems to be a ghost
and a giraffe who has better seats than
you
which is selfish when you're that tall
but that's mark's vision that two
friends can attend a concert together
when in reality i mean the old reality
both are really sitting at home what
great fun especially for the band
playing to an empty stadium
that's right a concert where no one has
to actually be at the concert or as
travis scott said now you tell me
[Applause]
but i must say i'm a little worried that
if we get ourselves too far away from
reality we won't be able to find our way
back
phony
used to be a bad thing and keeping it
real was good that's why i named this
show real time and not avatar time
we
we just went through a pandemic the last
thing i want is more virtual and that's
what the metaverse sounds like it's
going to be the pandemic year except
forever
you have to ask yourself why does mark
zuckerberg think living in a metaverse
would be so much better because look at
him
the dead eyes
the lack of recognizable human features
the painted on hair he's already an
avatar
i'm pretty sure that the person we think
is zuckerberg is a sim
well the real one lives on a yacht
staffed by a hundred beautiful women
where he plays pokemon go all day
this is the worst kind of person to make
the overlord of a new universe even
before the pandemic nearly three in ten
american males between 18 and 30 weren't
having sex
almost triple what that number was ten
years earlier the closest they come to
talking to a girl is alexa
and
[Applause]
and spending so much time on screens has
a lot to do with that this is the
phenomenon known as in cells
in cells
yeah that's short for involuntarily
celibate and it's not harmless
it never is when any society for
whatever reason creates men who are cut
off from women and it's not going well
here with the incels it has become a
toxic subculture of angry
misogynistic digital eunuchs
and the metaverse is only going to make
it meta worse because it's a vicious
cycle the more time you spend in the
virtual world the more you suck at
engaging in the real world
so the more you retreat into the virtual
which further atrophies your real social
skills including and most importantly
getting laid
you've uh you've heard of the cycle of
life this is the cycle of get a life
of men with no game who immersed
themselves ironically in games
and other substitutes for female
companionship especially hero movies oh
if they all want to be a hero so badly
all the movies are about how a hero will
rise there's always a hero rising
you want to be a hero rise from the
couch
rise from the couch
lose the cargo shorts
get a shirt with a collar
brush the crumbs off your beard
shave your beard and talk to a girl
earn it
earn being heroic by taking that long
brave walk across a room to ask someone
out the vast majority of men don't have
to fight wars anymore or hunt for food
and lord knows there aren't any real
loki's or green goblins to fight
the one place you can step up and show
courage is this be a hero to women
show yourself
show yourself you still have an ounce of
courage in your nut sack by risk
by risking rejection and going up to a
girl
and if it doesn't work out then you can
go home and spank it
you